smell down from the last lawmaking are
you guys doing I'm in Bosnia check it
out beautiful scenery isn't that amazing
alright guys we're gonna take a little
ride here and said I have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys enjoying the ride but where we
at what should people come see when
they're in said I'm outside I've never
been here what do you recommend
they're three different pages of city
walk down from a
an empire
Newark era from the Worcester area
have the mother
- sky scrapers dollar shopping mall by
festival after defeating the nature
that's why we have this for nature not
for the country where were where we add
[Music]
so we are now it's a sparkle because
separate from the rest of this
stooop and then entering the big area
Oh pudding
whether it's field the party person
[Applause]
[Music]
so now we're in the what's this is
[Music]
[Music]
all right
we hit some unexpected or brain
they today will bring you big video some
more of this amazing beautiful city you
know that you can watch on my channel I
did the a fool hour talking about the
history of Dex actual greatest genocide
after world war two that happened here
in san i EV oh you can have that in the
description that link you can you should
you should arrange something that it's
kind of not talked about much other
events are left not to be forgotten and
this is something that shouldn't be
forgotten so it doesn't happen again
and it happened here in this amazing
city said I go with so many amazing
wonderful people and I'm here and I'm
inviting you in so make sure you tune in
Chucky's what you again Pete Solly